تسعون ثانيه تفصلنا عن نهايه رمزيه للعالم
مجموعه من العلماء الامريكيين عرضوا هذه
الساعه الرمزيه كمقياس لنهايه العالم
وبدات الساعه تشير الى منتصف الليل الا
تسعين ثانيه
فكيف يتم تثبيت عقارب هذه الساعه الرمزيه
كل سنه يجتمع مجلس منظمه نشره علماء الذره
لاعاده ضبط عقربها هذا العام تم تقريب 10
ثواني عن مكان عليه اخذت النشره في
الاعتبار الحرب في اوكرانيا
وانتشار الاسلحه النوويه وازمه المناخ ما
ينفعش تسلمي
الاسلحه النوويه تذكر العالم بان تصعيد
الصراع عن طريق الصدفه او سوء التقدير هو
خطر الرهيب ولا تزال احتمالات خروج
الصراعات عن سيطره العالم عاليه
عام 45 على يد البيرنشتاين وعلماء اخرين
عملوا في برنامج صنع القنبله النوويه في
بدايه الحرب البارده عام 48 كانت البشريه
على بعد سبع دقائق من نهايه العالم وبعد
عامين تحركت عقارب الساعه من سبعه الى
ثلاث دقائق قبل منتصف الليل بعد ان يختبر
الاتحاد السوفيتي اسلحته النوويه الاولى
ومع نهايه الحرب البارده عام 91 تراجعت
السعه الى 17 دقيقه من منتصف الليل
ولو ان مشروع يوم القيامه يعد استعاره عن
مدى قرب البشريه من التدمير الذاتي الا ان
العلماء يحاولون من خلاله توعيه البشريه
لاعاده العقارب الى الوراء